il y à plus de 600 millions d'années
l'essentiel de la vie sur cette planète
étaient représentés par de petits
organismes flottant sur la mer de nos
jours des plantes microscopiques
similaires et prospère encore utilisant
l'énergie du soleil pour générer leur
propre tissu à partir de substances
chimiques contenus dans l'eau de mer
ce processus de photosynthèse la
transformation de l'anhydride carbonique
et de l'eau en substance organique est
la base de toute vie c'est très petites
plantes sont assimilés par une myriade
d'autres organismes
certaines sont de minuscules animaux à
peine plus grand que les plantes qu'ils
transportent dans leur bouche
cette communauté de plantes et d'animaux
flottant sur l'eau forme le plancton
perpétuellement en mouvement à travers
les mers sorte de gel fragile qui
s'effondrerait sans le support de l'eau
certains de ces animaux agite de petits
seal qui seul absorbe la lumière le
reste de leur corps étant parfaitement
transparent
des animalcules retiennent des plantes
microscopiques par tout un arsenal de
tentacules et de filaments
d'autres créatures comme les coraux les
anémones de mer se nourrissent
différemment se cramponnant au fond et
laissant au courant le soin de leur
apporter des particules nourricière
ainsi se nourrissent aussi certaines
formes de l'eau tueries et leurs
parentes l'étoile de mer en panier
une raie manta son envergure peut
atteindre plus de 5 m elle se nourrit
lorsque le plancton remonte vers la
surface
elle canalise l'eau vers sa bouche grâce
à deux pâles situés de part et d'autre
de sa tête et l'a fait passer ensuite à
travers des filtres situés sur les côtés
de sa gorge
encore plus grand et en fait le plus
grand des poissons le requin baleine qui
peut atteindre 15 mètres de long
d'autres poissons de taille infiniment
plus modestes vives de lui et autour de
lui se contentant de ces déchets le
requin baleine et passifs mais ardent au
fil du courant en tamisant le plancton
mais d'autres requins sont des
prédateurs conçu pour la vitesse leur
forme fuselée se perfectionne depuis 400
millions d'années
d'apparition beaucoup plus récentes
d'autres groupes font une charpente
composée d'eau et non de cartilage comme
la rocade
ils ont une morphologie plus
sophistiqués plus de stabilité de
maniabilité dans l'eau ces poissons
osseux sont de ceux qui aujourd'hui
dominent les maires
cette évolution a été très lente
il y a dix millions d'années des animaux
terrestres à sang chaud des mammifères
sont allés à l'eau les orques et polar
et leurs cousins les dauphins sont les
descendants directs de ces carnivores
dans la mer leur corps s'est
profondément modifiée mais pas leur goût
pour la chair comme en témoignent leurs
dents des membres de cette famille qui
vivent dans l'article ont même développé
une dent de taille extraordinaire voici
quelques-uns de ses narval ce sont tous
des mâles car eux seuls possèdent cette
défense spectaculaire qui peut mesurer
deux mètres cinquante ici des femelles
dont une avec son petit ceci enfin ce
sont deux jeunes mâles
on ne sait pas de manière précise les
usages que le narval fait de cet éperon
mais il semble qu'ils utilisent
essentiellement à la période des amours
c'est ce que tendrait en tout cas à
démontrer ces images très rare de deux
mâles en duel
la dernière famille de mammifères avoir
colonisé la mer descend de certaines
races d'ours
il s'agit des morses et de leurs cousins
les phoques venu à l'eau plus récemment
il y sont logiquement moins bien adaptés
ils n'ont pas comme les baleines perdu
leurs pattes et il continue à passer une
partie de leur vie sur terre notamment
pour donner naissance à leurs petits
quoi qu'il en soit ce sont d'excellents
nageurs
l'océan n'est pas un milieu uniforme
tout comme la terre il se compose de
zone diversifié habité par des créatures
spécifique que l'on trouve dans
certaines mères et pas dans l'autre le
lagon de corail par exemple constituent
un milieu aquatique tout à fait
originale les coraux constructeurs de
recife où madre port sont très exigeants
leur survie réclament outre à support
une lumière intense de l'eau
parfaitement pure de la chaleur toutes
conditions réunies sous les tropiques
particulièrement autour de ces petites
îles qui sont en réalité les sommes et
inondé de montagnes sous-marine
les variétés de coraux sont innombrables
certains sont mous ou légèrement
flexible mais la plupart ont un
squelette externe dur comme de la pierre
si la jungle sur terre et bien l'endroit
où l'on trouve le plus grand nombre et
la plus grande variété de formes de vie
alors un bond corail est assurément la
jungle des mères la diversité des
poissons et autres animaux est à couper
le souffle
certains comme ce poisson perroquet mach
le corps est lui même d'autres attrape
délicatement de petits organismes ou
particules en suspension dans l'eau
les marais parcourant le lagon
l'approvisionnent en eau fraîche et en
réserves de nourriture cette antenne
nerfs une poisson pêcheurs en embuscade
attend patiemment tout ce qui peut se
présenter de comestible il existe en
plusieurs versions celui-ci jaune vif et
cheveux grâce à une sorte d'antenne qui
se dresse sur le sommet de la tête
pour ce petit poisson c'est un appât
irrésistible fatale
si le banc de corail est l'équivalent
aquatique de la jungle
on peut comparer ces lits de varech des
eaux froides de la norvège aux forêts
sombres éternellement verte du nord
bien qu'elle paraisse déserte cette
forêt sous marine est riche de
nourriture et les canards et d'air le
savent ils se regroupent en bande à la
surface de l'eau à la verticale des
varech
puis il plonge il plonge et il vole si
l'on peut dire aussi bien dans l'eau que
dans les airs il affectionne la mer et
ne se trouve pratiquement jamais aux
abords d eau douce
il préfère pêcher les moules à marée
basse mais ne répugne pas à aller les
chercher à la nage ils sont capables de
descendre à 15 mètres de fond pendant
une minute et même davantage
le varech pousse dans toutes ses zones
côtières de la terre dans celle du sud
de l'australie vise des poissons expert
en camouflant
celui ci possède sur la queue à fauteuil
qui fait que l'on ne sait pas très bien
d'où il vient ni où il va mais bien plus
extraordinaire encore sont les algues
aux feuilles vertes qui l'entourent
car cette plante est en fait le
déguisement particulièrement
sophistiquée du dragon de mer une
espèces d'hippocampes que l'on arrive à
reconnaître si l'on parvient à discerner
le contour de son corps dans toute les
excroissances dont ils s'affublent il
possède en outre une toute petite bouche
avec laquelle ils attrapent des
crevettes qui naïvement viennent
chercher un abri dans ce qu'elle prenait
pour une algue flottante
de même qu'elle possède ses forêts la
mer à sète désert grandes étendues de
sable dont toute vie semble absente à
quelques exceptions près on y rencontre
occasionnellement un poisson égaré ou
encore un oursin extrayant du sable
quelques particules de nourriture
construire un abri dans ce sable
nécessite des techniques particulières
des congrès cimente quelques grains de
sable avec du mucus pour former un tube
auquel il arrive l'heure que tout en
collectant le plancton avec leur bouche
le poisson lame lui est capable de se
bâtir son abri de manière tout à fait
instantanée les champs de plancton
flottant dont dépend de tant de poissons
les océans doivent rester proche de la
surface afin de pouvoir capter les
rayons du soleil les lagons de corail et
les varech ont aussi un besoin vital de
lumière mais à partir de 100 mètres de
profondeur celle ci n'est plus
perceptible et la plus grande partie des
fonds océaniques se situe beaucoup plus
bas même près de la surface
l'exploration exigent souvent une
lumière artificielle
certains poissons sont capables d'en
produire eux mêmes ils l'utilisent dans
leur quête de nourriture et pour
communiquer entre eux les poissons
lantern dispose de sorte de batteries
constitué de colonie de petits doigts
que terry qui vivent dans une poche sous
leurs yeux des bactéries qui émettent
constamment de la lumière par réaction
chimique le poisson allumé ou éteint
cette lumière en ouvrant ou en abaissant
une pellicule de peau semblables à une
paupière
l'amphi pas de géant qui se déplacent
lourdement dans ces abysses est un
crustacé sur lequel on possède peu de
renseignements
ans
même à 900 mètres de fond on trouve des
formes de vie pratiquement tout ce qui
vit dans ses profondeurs s'alimente de
corps mort venue d'en haut
les mx in qui rassemble des anguilles
n'ont pas de mâchoire mais débouche
souvent toulouse qui les fixe solidement
aux carcasses dont elles se nourrissent
la partie la plus profonde des océans
échappe au courant c'est aux obscurs et
froides sont donc aussi pratiquement
immobiles
en surface par contre l'eau est
perpétuellement en mouvement les vagues
produites par les tempêtes peuvent se
dérouler sur des milliers de kilomètres
cette mouvance de la mer est capital
pour ceux qui vivent car elle permet à
l'eau d'absorber l'oxygène de l'air
à l'intérieur de l'océan circulent des
courants puissants du à la rotation de
la terre qui au niveau de l'équateur
suscite une impulsion vers l'ouest est
due également à la chaleur du soleil et
qui réchauffe les eaux tropicales et les
poussent vers l'épaule cela provoque
dans l'océan des remous considérable
semblable au tourbillon engendrés par
les marées mais à une échelle beaucoup
plus grande dans le pacifique le courant
équatoriale se divisent vers le sud
il descend jusqu'à la nouvelle zélande
dans l'océan indien au sud
le mouvement est pratiquement circulaire
au nord il doit contourner le triangle
formé par l'inde dans l'atlantique
le courant chaud se dirigeant vers le
nord gulfstream rencontre un courant
froid venant de l'arctique au large des
côtes de terre-neuve dans une zone dont
les eaux sont parmi les plus fertiles du
globe
ces courants tourbillonnant font
remonter à la surface une nourriture
riche et la vie peut s'y épanouir en
eaux peu profondes au dessus du plateau
continental en cet endroit les animaux
viennent faire moisson de tout le
potentiel de richesse de l'océan c'est
kaplan apparentés aux éperlans européens
se nourrissent de plancton
en mai ils se rassemblent en banc
immense pour se multiplier
certains s'accouplent au large d'autres
s'efforcent de venir déposer leurs oeufs
sur les plages pour les mettre à l'abri
d'autres poissons affamés chaque vague
les amène à la sab le mans par dizaines
de milliers
le nombre de leurs the défie toute
estimation tous les mâles et la plupart
des femelles mourrons ici
sur la ligne de marée haute toute la
substance que le capelan a pu tirer du
plancton tout ce qu'il a assimilé dans
sa propre chair va maintenant profiter
aux oiseaux
les puffins se partagent les capellans
mort et les mourants
les fous de bassan plonge parmi ces
nécrophage pour dévorer les poissons
vivant et à la sab le mans les kaplan
s'approche de la côte thèse avant leur
arrivée en eaux peu profondes
il attire des hordes de phoques
des chasseurs infiniment plus grands les
mégaptère participer au festin
à chaque lampe et en surface ces
baleines engloutissent des tonnes d'eau
et d'emilie et de crustacés de petits
poissons
une orgie qui dure plusieurs semaines
avant même que ces bancs immense de
caplan mort n'entre en décomposition ils
sont rejoints par d'autres constitué de
mollusques personne ne sait d'où ils
viennent ni pourquoi ils ont péri en
cire en nombre toujours est il que cette
masse de nourriture annonce l'arrivée de
nombreux affamés
pour attraper ces gloutons anapa n'est
même plus nécessaire
il se précipite sur tout ce qui se
présente même un hameçon ou un crochet
nous en étaient les pêcheurs de
terre-neuve vont ainsi des pêches
miraculeuses notamment de calmars
conditionné et expédié aussitôt par
centaines de tonnes au japon où leur
chair est particulièrement prisé
leriche plancton de terre-neuve attire
également des millions de mac row dont
une bonne partie finira dans les cales
des flottille de bateaux usines
miraculeuse ces pêches ne sont pas pour
autant inépuisable au cours des
dernières années l'homme a ratissé les
ressources de l'océan au point d'y
modifier les équilibres de la vie